[Music]
this is not the music of War not far
from the front line is aparicha this
band are busking and playing Rock
Classics the Summer sun is out and the
people of danipro are making the most of
it chefchenko Park is where they come to
relax and look over the dinipro river
really when you hear the a
you remember about that but that doesn't
feel like this and here people are just
relaxed as they used to be this city was
hit by missiles a week ago
we haven't played for a year we didn't
go anywhere we didn't give any
performances because it's painful for us
but despite all these missiles we still
go out and give performances because
Ukraine's free and it's very beautiful
we're all very nervous but life's going
on still we will continue to live to
sing to create to love to raise our
children
cafes are open children playing the
streets the Nipper looks like any other
City bustling with energy but the fear
of Russian attacks is always there
safe but when the Night Comes usually
that's when attacks happen it's scary
but as long as I'm not alone I have
people nearby
for some the evening is a chance to
unwind
when you look around it's hard to
believe the nearest front line is just
over 100 kilometers away when the war
started scenes like this people outside
enjoying themselves like they are today
would have been Unthinkable
in a popular Italian restaurant it's
business as usual and there's always
time to pause for Instagram at this
well-known Eatery
for the war although we have a bomb
shelter and when there is an air alert
our guests go downstairs we're lucky
because at times the city was shelled
heavily the entire city was anxious but
people got used to it
but even as people are drinking and
potting there is a reminder that life is
still not quite normal yet
curfews and martial law are still in
place across the country meaning these
people have to be home by midnight I
said Big Al Jazeera denipro Ukraine